by the way I'm like in the thoughtful
beautiful reverie from the film that you
directed then of course you come out and
I start looking at your double Denim and
your style
and I love your style this is gorgeous
yeah yeah of course I mean you are the
glamor Cover Girl this month
[Applause]
like you have broke the internet with uh
such looks as well let's see like the
the cashmere bralette you were wearing
it looks like you're contemplating your
next move and basically then you pause
the entire world uh commenting on your
top like did you know that was going to
be such a thing no I didn't and then you
had this Jingle Ball look that also
everyone was obsessed with and
contemplating
what's the decision here I like I'm so
interested and I feel like a lot of
people were debating it right yeah I
mean I thought it's like a corset and so
I threw it on with jeans and I knew I
wanted to dance there
because I was going with my nephews so I
threw my sneakers on and I thought I
look cool I felt cool I felt great and
then like I woke up the next morning and
and I was like oh my gosh I guess I I
don't know I didn't know that that was
such a thing to I don't know I mean I
just I was I I don't think about it I
really don't I like to go and have fun
and the way you were talking about
fashion it transported me right to your
film rare objects which you directed and
there's such a poetry to this film it's
hard for me to describe because I feel
like it's about so many things but what
is it for you why did you want to make
this fun in your performance and it is
incredible I mean I I've been working on
it for a while
um and trying to figure it out quite
honestly because of its many themes and
what is the most important and what is
it that I really wanted to put out there
and I I felt like it was that the female
friendship is so key and the
connectivity of strangers how that can
be very healing to people
and also watching our main character
experience
such a real trauma in her life
that we don't
run from you know we really show it and
but also watching her
continue living and continue trying to
make her life
into something that she wants it to be
and so ultimately I felt like the movie
at the end I hope uh leaves the audience
with hope and I feel like all the
characters in this movie they intersect
and they're open to listening or sharing
and being vulnerable and I feel like
that was something that I wanted to put
out there because that's that is a
beautiful human quality and we don't
often celebrate that in in life
I think
oh wow we have a clip of rare objects
take a look
what's your name
uh Peter Peter Kessler
I'm Diana
yes
let me just have a minute to think of
course yes
when you come in on scene because you
meet her a scene before in the film you
are literally wondering
it it's such a wild juxtaposition your
performance that it takes you a back and
you're like wait I whoa this is the same
person it's an it's just it's incredible
congratulations like it is
I have to I have to I mean you know I'm
such a fan of yours and and everything
that you've done in your career has been
like an inspiration and and you and it
gives me confidence because it's like oh
you when you started producing it was
like oh we can do that women can do that
we can and so thank you I mean we're you
just you give so much so
[Applause]
yes yes I'm free
it's true I put this couch out here
because actually recently you're in this
Off-Broadway play The Wanderers and
everybody who saw it was just in love
and your co-star and bestie is actually
here right Lucy prayer
[Applause]
oh
thank you
hello
hi what's up okay so Lucy you're in pain
what is paint I'm trying to figure it
out it's Owen Wilson yeah you think he's
Bob Ross but he's got a little more game
than Bob Ross or at least as far as we
know fun fact apparently
um women were really hot for Bob Ross
and did not just watch his PBS special
for the art well then maybe oh maybe
Carl noggle had as much game as Bob Ross
then maybe it is a little more of a
biopic than we thought I think it's like
an ASMR sexy hot you know guy thing
um but
um is it true that you think that you
would be a good food critic oh I would
love it yes I do so well will you be a
food critic yes with us all right let's
go
[Music]
foreign foreign